[Music]
back in the 1950s and early 60s if they
had full-blown respiratory distress
syndrome more than 90% would die
it occurs in this most severe form for
prematurely born babies when the lungs
have not yet matured
[Music]
as a child I was born in Auburn New York
wonderful place for a child to grow up
so at age eight or nine I've already
thought I was wanted to be a scientist I
was able to gather gather materials to
make a huge Tesla coil which was 15,000
volts oh I had to killed a lot power my
parents mother proper Victorian lady
born in 1880 now my father an attorney
and general practice was also an
intellectual person it was obvious to me
that my parents were pleased but when I
brought home good grades so I graduated
at the top of my class and I only
applied to one University that was
Cornell and difficult I went there so I
did college medical school five years
five and a half years
[Music]
the questions that I came was assigned
to study dealt with nerve gases sarin
taboo gases like that the effects of
those agents anta : s theresa agents on
the lungs so I became a physiologist
when I became a lung physiologist at
spite of being out of school just a
couple years and being woefully ignorant
about it but then a marvelous thing
happened the army chemical Center had
contracts research contracts with people
at universities I was assigned one of
those for a contract atharva School of
Public Health where they were doing long
research related to artificial
ventilation of assistance for soldiers
with respiratory problems
Jeri Mead was studying lung mechanics
but then Ted Radford came to that
department to do research with sherry
and he Ted took a very physical chemical
approach to lung problems he was curious
in the problems of oxygen uptake through
the lungs basically how much area is
required in the lungs between the air
and the capillary blood to provide an
adequate pathway for uptake of oxygen
it occurs by diffusion that's not an
active transport so the only way you can
get enough transferred fast enough to
support metabolic processes especially
under exercise is to have a very large
area
that was a given that was supported by
morphometric management's cutting up
tissue and the slices doing geometric
measurements on them and you think there
was the estimated area which turned out
to be huge
if you unrolled the area of the small
air spaces in the lawn it would cover
for one adult would cover practically a
football field
Ted Radford didn't think you could fold
up a football field and get it inside
the chest of a human adult and so he
wanted to estimate the area by a
different method not histologic more
symmetric methods and he took the
physical-chemical approach and he did
really a very clever kind of experiment
he said I want to know the area of the
surface of the lung and so what property
does that have that would have enabled
me to estimate it and he knew about
surface tension it's equivalent to the
surface free energy of a liquid surface
and so he thought well if I can guess
what the surface tension is in the lungs
then I can divide that and the the
energy on the surface in order to
calculate the area so an on morphometric
way of doing it but then he had to find
out what the energy of the alveolar
surfaces totaled up to be and he did
that by doing making pressure-volume
studies on the lungs so then if you knew
the park would assume a surface tension
you could take that simple equation that
divided the energy
surface tension and that would you come
out with the area that's what he did and
he got a new only one-tenth of
histologic morphometric measurements I
mean a tenfold discrepancy between the
two methods and each method was supposed
to be okay now what's going on here well
I talked with Ted about it and asked him
to explain what was going on know what
the method actually meant and Ted sort
of drew himself up to his full height as
a electrical engineer and said well you
wouldn't understand it I'm usually a
mild-mannered but they've got under my
skin and I thought
clenching my teeth I will understand
this you know without your help
that big discrepancy no bothered me and
so I tried to think where are the errors
in this are there errors of method are
there thinking errors of concept so I
thought well he's using data and an
equation but he's just assuming a
surface tension for the inside of the
log what if that's wrong so I thought
well we can turn the calculations
backwards and we can say we know what
the energy is the surface energy and we
know what the area is so we can do the
division the other way around and
calculate the surface tension in there
from the energy and the area from the
pressure-volume diagram you got an
energy and so you could calculate
in steps during the deflation curve in
the pressure-volume curve what the
surface tension would be at that point
during change along volume from Maximum
to minimum
the result was astonishing it was
absolutely amazing because the surface
tension at full amount of volume was of
annual close to serum to tissue juice to
head to blood and all that then fell
down to a value at minimal log volume
close to zero surface tension that's a
remarkable thing and I knew enough of I
studied enough about surface tension at
that point to know that that's not just
an ectoplasmic manifestation there has
to be a substance to do that that takes
us to the next step which is there is a
substance and it behaves like a
surfactant in our material that can
lower the surface tension of water
when I got the studying the effects of
surface tension in the lungs there was a
wealth of ignorance the people I talked
to the physiologist I talked to didn't
really get it and it was a hard slog
because as I went along did some
experiments I thought I got useful
information but it didn't didn't get
much acceptance among my peers so you
know when we wrote up our initial
findings trying to send it to science
they turned it down when we were still
at the as the crude extract level so you
can you can see why people that
prestigious magazine would say well this
isn't good enough we need to know what
it really is so trial and error takings
available chemicals all off-the-shelf
and mixing them together and trying to
imitate the properties pretty crude by
today's standards but though we're
talking half a century ago you probably
would be surprised to learn if you
haven't already that in those days
chromatography was in its very infancy
and you had to work to get a lot of
material and work to purify it and then
characterize it by methods that were
very laborious compared to what are
available today so the beginnings went
very slowly but by using the developing
chromatographic methods and comparing
with synthetic compounds melting points
no more than points
determinations of molecular weight
methods of that sort far removed from
tandem aspect that we have today and
better methods than that even so the
studies of composition what's slowly but
it became evident that the material was
built like a like a membrane like a cell
membrane richard phospholipids
sprinkling of neutral lipids some
cholesterol and some proteins no in an
in a sort of normal kind of cell
membrane there'd be roughly 50 percent
protein
50 percent lipids of various sorts in
this membrane like material that we were
getting out on how long it was only
eight percent protein and the rest was
predominantly phospholipid and one in
particular died fellows who will
phosphatidylcholine
and that made up about 60% of the of the
mass of the material so that was a good
pointer because saturated highly polar
phospholipid is wonderful to make films
at water surfaces that was already known
and another part of the community so
that was a hint for us and we began to
see what we could do with that
particular molecule DPP C for short
you
she did that at Christmastime in 1957
and I showed her everything though the
balance and the results and what ideas I
had about it and she went back to Boston
and she and Jerry Mead set up a
surveillance of their own and made
extracts from the logs of babies who had
died and found or didn't find I should
say sir fact that in the lungs of those
babies who had died with respiratory
distress syndrome but if the babies were
mature enough if they made more than
about a thousand grams at birth then
they could find good surface activity so
they got enough data to write a paper
that publish it came out in January of
1959 so so the next Christmas I got my
Christmas present from them when that
was published some of the doubters began
to think there might be something to it
and many many people around the world
got interested and began devoting
research time to it lots of people
trying to work on producing surfactants
some of them synthetic some of them
natural variants I definitely the
synthetic I didn't like the idea of
animal derived surfactants because of
sensitivity and contamination
considerations so I tried to design a
completely synthetic one which I did
which arose welcome company I said was
no one back then the licensed it was
patented by the University of California
and they licensed introduced it in
quantities sufficient
to do proper clinical trials and the
results were again very promising but
now based on much larger numbers of
patients by the time the FDA approved it
the number of patients in the study
really exceeded the number of patients
in any other clinical study that had
been done so FDA was justified well I
think you know in approving it now
taking all birth weights into account
the mortality who are our new yes it's
less than 5% we have very dramatic
graphs but we have to qualify that by
saying that care and the newborn
intensive care unit is advanced
tremendously since the early days
neonatology as a specialty has come in
to be it didn't even exist at the
beginning and one has to give proper
credit
well surfactant addition to that
armamentarium it's a relatively recent
one really since 1990 so that's 40 years
after the beginning of the field
[Music]
from then until 2000 mortality curved us
with a practically to zero I still get
the occasional letter a proud mother who
thanks me for my contributions to the
field that's very satisfying
you
you
you